[Musique]
je vous avais dit qu'il viendrait la
famille blues ont tourné quelques images
selon lui des images de campagne
donc tu te présente aux élections c'est
simple j'ai envie de faire partie du
problème est qu'elle a enfin réussi à se
rassembler te voilà pas les affaires en
fout l'camp d'ici mais pas pour très
longtemps
je vous propose de retourner là où les
choses ont commencé à dire faire preuve
j'ai fait une grosse bêtise je suis
kukucka on dirait que beaucoup de choses
ont changé au cours des années
ce soir je me bats en bleu pour la
première fois depuis cinq ans enfin
peut-être pas tant que ça
dites moi quelle est la raison qui a
rassemblé toute la famille au même
endroit cette fois ci mais pour ce
nouveau nouveau départ c'est différent
salut je n'aime pas du tout
parce que les blues reçoivent enfin la
récompense qu'il pense mériter le prix
de la vanille de l'anr de l'année au
fait venir la famille qui nous donne ça
on se donne à nous mêmes je vois parce
que personne n'aurait jamais voté pour
nous parce qu'il n'y a rien de mieux que
la famille pour vous rappeler alors non
je dirais je salue le sait michael je
suis venu pour sommet du bonheur
recorder qui revoit là je croyais qu'on
pouvait tout se faire arrested
development
c'est l'ensemble au revoir et à dieu
surtout on voit ce soir on se voit ce
soir seulement sur les tricks